good morning John I come to you today
the series of ones and zeros passed
through tubes made of copper and glass
streams instantaneously whenever you
want to see it in fact wherever you want
to see it in the entire world in an age
of such wonders I cannot help but ask
the obvious question why are we still
doing television at all I did it just
the other day sat down in front of a
television the last time I had cable
inside of my house was 2002 so of the
small little changes that have happened
in those 10 years sort of come rushing
on to me all at once and I have to say
it freaking suck well the joys of
television used to be flipping channels
now this is no longer possible because
something in the last 10 years has
necessitated a five-second gap between
when I push the UP button
next channel comes up a flipping isn't
supposed to be a thing anymore because
we have this wonderful thing called the
guy if you can find the buttons on this
monolithic remote that allow you to
access and interact with the guide good
on you but once you do not only was I
forced to scroll over one advertisement
for every four channels I saw huge
expanses of the guide were not
accessible to me there were channels
that I could not see why aren't they in
my guide it should be a fairly simple
technical challenge to overcome I want
to see the channels that I can see and
then I realize hey this is NBC channel
712 no NBC is supposed be like four five
or six
it's NBC why is it 712 so I asked my
friend Dave this and he's like Oh NBC is
lower down as well when you upgrade to
high definition you get high-definition
and standard-definition NBC why do I
want the SD NBC if I have the HD one and
the HD one the one that you want to
watch is in the 700s I'm not going to
talk a lot about the content of
television because YouTube has crap too
you know I am a little bit frustrated by
the advertisements running on my science
general right now for a show called
Finding Bigfoot I do think there's a
Squatch in these woods
Finding Bigfoot on Animal Planet which
is supposed to be about animals not
fakin well I guess insane people
wandering around in forests or
technically animals too I finally find
something that I would like to watch it
and variably in the wrong aspect ratio
because there is good television out
there there's plenty of television that
I would like to watch unfortunately it's
on like seven of the 130 channels that
they give you for those channels aren't
even cable I could get them with
antennas so there's three channels that
I'm paying a hundred and thirty dollars
a month for well I could be eight
dollars for Netflix get some of the best
television of all time and never have to
watch a single advertisement because I'm
freaking paying for it oh what's that I
hear you have to pay for cable and you
still get advertisements great an
average hour of television about 36%
advertisements if you include product
placements which means if the average
person in America watches five hours of
television a day which apparently they
do that mean that they will in their
lives spend 4.5 years watching
advertisements I have done the math my
friends here in the world of YouTube a
15-second pre-roll on a four minute long
video is seven times less advertising
than you get on television not only that
I think that in general online video is
more engaging it's more likely to be
what you want it's more can
he's a much better interface it's easier
to discover cool new stuff I think it's
more rewarding so let me be possibly the
first and hopefully not the last person
to say everyone cancel your cable
subscriptions it will be okay John and I
are doing our part with a total of at
least six videos on YouTube per week if
you subscribe to vlogbrothers scishow
and crash course which will launch
January 25th you can more than double
that number if you subscribe to
hankgames and truther fail as well and i
don't see why you wouldn't thank you to
the world of online video and for you
the pioneering viewers who are making
this transition not just possible but
necessary John I will see you on Tuesday
it sounds so weird